okay today for our daily cancellation i
have to issue a cancellation
begrudgingly
not because i want to with no personal
animosity behind it
um in fact in performing this
cancellation ritual
i am following the rules and customs of
our modern society i am enforcing the
rules
their rules not my own these not my
rules
the subject today is a young woman by
the name of morgan bullock
and she was profiled by the bbc recently
that profile has gotten some attention
online let me uh
it's about a five minute video i don't
play the whole thing but let me play
just a clip of that for you watch this
people saying that i shouldn't be irish
dancing because i'm
black and i don't look like most irish
dancers
but i saw it for the first time at a
recital and it was just
the coolest thing ever to me
[Music]
when you went into those irish dancing
classes were you the only
african-american girl in the class
yeah i was always the only one in my
class did that ever have any effect on
you or how did that make you feel
i mean obviously it's hard to miss
someone who's actually their face
matches their legs at the competitions
because you know the
there's like the tanner you like there's
a lot of time yeah a lot of
tanner but it's hard to miss someone
who's african-american
i don't think i ever considered it an
issue it was definitely something that i
took note of
but i'd grown up in a predominantly
white area so it wasn't something that
i was uncomfortable about
after going viral with her irish dance
scene the reaction was
overwhelmingly positive but there were a
few who thought that what she was doing
was inappropriate the negative comments
that people were leaving
under the video what were people saying
just early on like shortly after posting
it some people were saying
that what i was doing was cultural
appropriation
just because i don't look like what you
would typically picture an irish dancer
to look like
but i mean so were they saying because
you weren't irish
and because you were not white that you
shouldn't be
performing irish dancing yeah basically
that's what they were saying you were
misappropriating
the irish dancing culture i mean my
understanding of the term is that it
means
when you're taking something from
another culture claiming it as your own
without recognizing where it comes from
and that's
couldn't be further from what i'm doing
like it's important for people to
recognize that there's a difference
between appropriation and appreciation
i think people use the term
appropriation without without knowing
what it really means
okay so she's a she's an irish dancer
black woman
uh from where they say virginia now
first of all they didn't show an example
of the supposed
negative comments that this woman has
received but it's obvious that the
negative comments were way way way
outnumbered by the positive which is
good
and let me be clear about this i i agree
with everything she said
i agree that she's not guilty of
appropriation i agree that this is
appreciation
i agree that if you see a type of dance
you know for example
and you like it and you admire it and
you want to do it
that is by definition appreciation and
should be embraced
i also agree that if cultural
appropriation means anything at all
it must mean taking something from
another culture
and pretending that you came up with it
or that your culture came up with it
so if she did an irish dance and like
claim that she invented the style or
something or that it's a style she
inherited from her ancestors or
or whatever then then yeah that would be
i suppose appropriation
but of course she didn't do that and
almost nobody would do that because that
would just be bizarre you know
she she likes irish dance that's why she
got involved in it
and she's not trying to she has no
interest in in trying to
degrade irish dance or or or hide from
the history of it
she likes it that's the whole point here
she admires it
uh you wouldn't give so much of your
life and so many hours of
of your day to practicing it if you
didn't admire it
however everything she's saying and the
definitions she's giving
even though she's right and she's being
reasonable
none of that is actually what the left
says about cultural appropriation
according to the left it doesn't matter
if you appreciate the culture
it doesn't matter if you think that uh
it's cool or
or beautiful or whatever else to do a
dance or to take a style
or anything else from another culture if
you are not of that culture
is appropriation those are the left's
rules and since the left's rules those
are the rules of society
in fact here's an example this is also
from the bbc just to
uh just to frame this here
this is an example also from the bbc a
couple years ago
another thing of another cultural
appropriation controversy
but you'll notice that though the bbc
defended
miss bullock they take a very different
tone here
if you look at this um headline prom
dress
prompts cultural appropriation row
and then it goes on i'm not going to
read the entire article but maybe you
remember this case
a white white girl high school student
in utah decided to wear a traditional
chinese dress
to her prom and she posted pictures
because she was proud of it and she
thought it was cool and
you know she liked the style and
everything and
it went viral in a negative way i mean
overwhelmingly negative response um
one of the one widely shared response
from a twitter user jeremy lam
said my culture is not your effing prom
dress
and a lot of criticisms like that and
finally the
uh the girl was forced to take down the
pictures
she tried to say that she didn't mean it
to be negative she was appreciating
chinese culture
but she had to take it down and she
apologized now
if wearing a chinese dress to prom is
appropriation from the chinese
then doing an irish dance and performing
in river dance is appropriation from the
irish
there's no way around it now i know the
way around it
the attempted way around it is um
is is in fact they they
uh in one of the articles i think in the
in the bbc
article they say that appropriation is
oftentimes when a dominant culture
takes from a minority culture
but first of all that's just ad hoc
silliness okay you're inventing
definitions
as you go along adjusting the terms
uh as you go along according to what it
will be politically useful to you so
that
that's not a legitimate way of doing
going about this anyway
but secondly irish culture is not
dominant
or in the majority anywhere um
except for maybe in ireland even though
even there i did you know
it's it's debatable at this point
i and i would submit that black culture
in america is
quite a bit more dominant and has quite
a bit more power in america than irish
culture
i don't think there's any denying that
so no matter how no matter how you slice
it or try to define it
this is appropriation and cancellations
must be handed out i'm afraid
i don't want to do it but those are the
rules
unless of course we want to all
admit that the whole idea of cultural
appropriation
is nonsense a culture actually
cannot be appropriated like even if i
were to become a hindu
and and give myself a hindi name and
wear the traditional attire
that hindus wear and i were to celebrate
diwali and other hindu
uh holidays all the rest of it i
wouldn't be appropriating anything from
the people of india
because i'm not depriving them of their
culture by partaking in it myself
this is not a zero-sum game with
cultures a culture doesn't lose
something
just because someone outside of it is is
influenced by it or imitates it
i mean they used to say imitation is
this is the you know the highest form of
flattery
that's all it's imma it's not
appropriation
it is at worst imitation okay
what i would really say is you're
partaking in it it's it's pr
i would say it's it's more participation
than even imitation but fine if you want
to call it imitation that's fine too
and and not only do cultures not
lose anything by having other people
imitate it
they actually gain cultures gain
influence they gain power they gain
recognition
by being you know quote unquote
appropriated in this way
and this is really obvious with the
irish dance thing okay
you know irish dance traditional irish
dance um
now it's being performed by uh you know
black woman in america and it's getting
getting media attention because of that
anyone who's a fan of irish dance
whether you're irish or not
you're not to see that as a negative
that's great just more attention more
people getting involved in it
you have a young you have younger
generations more diverse
generations of people getting involved
fantastic great stuff
why would anyone have a problem with
that well it should be the same thing
with a with a chinese
prom dress uh it's just
it's spreading the influence of that
culture more people are getting exposed
to it more people are saying oh this is
a beautiful dress
what could possibly be the problem with
that to have someone seeing a dress
a a traditional
chinese cultural dress is like that's
beautiful i want more people to see this
beautiful dress
there's there's no way for a sane person
to interpret that
in in a negative way but of course there
are a lot of insane people in this
culture so it's one way or the other
you know if we don't want to cancel um
this young woman
for for for doing irish dance which i
certainly don't want to
then the only other option is to say
we're going to cancel cultural
appropriation
the whole concept is canceled we're
getting rid of it because it's nonsense
and uh if you like a part of someone
else's culture
and you want to imitate it partake in it
whatever go for it
that's what cult that's that's how
cultures work perfectly fine
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up
and share it with all your friends